66 percent of the [Usage] Panel
found it unacceptable in 1988,
58 percent in 1999,
and 48 percent in 2011."
Ah, the Usage Panel,
that trusted body of language authorities
who is getting more lenient about this.
Now, what I hope you're thinking right now is,
"Wait, who's on the Usage Panel?
And what should I do with their pronouncements?"
If you look in the front matter
of American Heritage Dictionaries,
you can actually find the names
of the people on the Usage Panel.
But who looks at the front matter of dictionaries?
There are about 200 people on the Usage Panel.
They include academicians,
journalists, creative writers.
There's a Supreme Court justice on it
and a few linguists.
As of 2005, the list includes me.
(Applause)
Here's what we can do for you.
We can give you a sense
of the range of opinions about contested usage.
That is and should be the extent of our authority.
We are not a language academy.
About once a year, I get a ballot
that asks me about whether new uses,
new pronunciations, new meanings, are acceptable.
Now here's what I do to fill out the ballot.
I listen to what other people are saying and writing.
I do not listen to my own likes
and dislikes about the English language.
I will be honest with you:
I do not like the word "impactful,"
but that is neither here nor there
in terms of whether "impactful" is becoming common usage
and becoming more acceptable in written prose.
So to be responsible,
what I do is go look at usage,
which often involves going to look
at online databases such as Google Books.
Well, if you look for "impactful" in Google Books,
here is what you find.
Well, it sure looks like "impactful"
is proving useful
for a certain number of writers,
and has become more and more useful
over the last 20 years.
Now, there are going to be changes
that all of us don't like in the language.
There are going to be changes where you think,
"Really?
Does the language have to change that way?"
What I'm saying is,
we should be less quick
to decide that that change is terrible,
we should be less quick to impose
our likes and dislikes about words on other people,
and we should be entirely reluctant
to think that the English language is in trouble.
It's not. It is rich and vibrant and filled
with the creativity of the speakers who speak it.
In retrospect, we think it's fascinating
that the word "nice" used to mean silly,
and that the word "decimate"
used to mean to kill one in every 10.
(Laughter)
We think that Ben Franklin was being silly
to worry about "notice" as a verb.
Well, you know what?
We're going to look pretty silly in a hundred years
for worrying about "impact" as a verb
and "invite" as a noun.
The language is not going to change so fast
that we can't keep up.
Language just doesn't work that way.
I hope that what you can do
is find language change not worrisome
but fun and fascinating,
just the way dictionary editors do.
I hope you can enjoy being part
of the creativity that is continually remaking
our language and keeping it robust.
So how does a word get into a dictionary?
It gets in because we use it
and we keep using it,
and dictionary editors are paying attention to us.
If you're thinking, "But that lets all of us decide
what words mean,"
I would say, "Yes it does,
and it always has."
Dictionaries are a wonderful guide and resource,
but there is no objective dictionary authority out there
that is the final arbiter about what words mean.
If a community of speakers is using a word
and knows what it means, it's real.
That word might be slangy,
that word might be informal,
that word might be a word that you think
is illogical or unnecessary,
but that word that we're using,
that word is real.
Thank you.
(Applause)